at first glance letting goals in
Afghanistan set their exams seems a step
in the right direction
Ary school goals have effectively been
banned from classrooms since the Taliban
returned to power in August last year on
Tuesday education officials announced
that girls across much of the country
would be allowed to sit their High
School graduation exams
but many students aren't happy at being
given so little time to prepare
they've been away from school for more
than a year and were only given a few
days notice of the tests some pupils
describe the exams as meaningless
I'm in a very bad state right now
because we have an exam for grade 12 and
we haven't studied a single book for it
we are here to answer 140 questions
without knowing anything we know nothing
what answers should we give and for what
we don't want much we only want to study
in our country because it is our right
half of the population is women we have
a rush and they should give us our right
to prosper officials have given a series
of excuses for school closures ranging
from a lack of money to a shortage of
teachers they've also said they'll
reopen once in Islamic curriculum has
been finalized or a national policy on
Modest School attire has been created
that still hasn't happened and some have
been going to school in secret there are
fears though that without being able to
pass the school leaving exam very few
will be able to apply to University
Andrea van wyk Al Jazeera